good morning Hank it's Sunday June 28
2009 and I'm angry
so Hank as you know in our
two-and-a-half year conversation we've
now uploaded more than 500 videos
congratulations by the way and thanks to
the awesomeness of nerdfighters our
videos have been watched lots and lots
of times but not everyone who's watching
them is awesome so I'm going to read you
some comments that people have posted in
the last week on vlogbrothers videos
these are all direct quotes except for
every time they use a curse word I'm
going to use the name of a famous
American poet you Walt Whitman a aDNA
st. Vincent Millay go Emily Dickinson
your mom thanks for the advice you
pathetic piece of e Cummings but I think
I'm gonna pass you Robert frosting Nikki
Giovanni get a life nerd you're a virgin
ah hey bro you need to go outside and
get some fresh air into you or a
girlfriend I need to get a girlfriend
into me I think that shows a fundamental
lack of comprehension about how babies
are made you are a complete and Sexton
stupid okay couple things first off if
you're accusing someone of being stupid
you should probably know that in that
context your is a contraction at anytime
you're contracting you are it spelled y
ou you apostrophe re oh my god YouTube
before you click submit' comment read
your comment and ask yourself do I mean
you are and if you do secondly accusing
someone else of being stupid implies
that you have the intellectual facility
to know the difference between stupid
and smart a case that is not bolstered
when you use stupid as a noun
this video is so Ralph Waldo Emerson gay
you're gay you're a gay nerd gay okay
YouTube apparently we have to have a
talk about this because you're obsessed
with calling things gay so I thought
this was pretty widely known but I guess
I have to explain what gay means being
gay means that you're attracted to
people of the same gender so a video
can't be gay because it doesn't have a
gender Hank I never thought I would have
to do this but I think I have to explain
to YouTube how insults work when you're
insulting someone what you want to do is
you want to make them feel bad about
themselves so you want to paint them
with character traits or identities that
are bad so for instance Hank if I wanted
to hurt your
I might say that you're a selfish
coal-fired power plant but to read
YouTube comments you would think that
the worst thing in the world to be is
not a selfish coal-fired power plant but
a gay virgin nerd we have this weird
thing in the world where you don't get
insulted for what you do you get
insulted for who you are and ultimately
gay will never work as an insult because
it's not bad so you want to call me a
gay nerd virgin that's fine
believe me when I say you are not
embarrassing me you are embarrassing
yourself you want to insult me take a
lesson from this guy you want kind of
like that guy from wild hogs wall what
guy from what Tim Allen I look like Tim
Allen Wow Hank that's a bird
nerdfighters on Tuesday I'm going to do
a question Tuesday so please leave great
questions in comments Hank I hope you're
having fun with mom and dad in the
Katherine and you'll see me on Tuesday